for much of the past few months it's
been almost impossible for most people
to cross here in a region where
cross-border links are historically
strong but now some restrictions have
been relaxed and Germans living in the
border region can cross into Denmark as
well as some tourists planning a long
stay if you are not a German citizen
from Silesia hallstatt health then you
have to have a purpose for going into
Denmark it could be you have a vacation
with six nights stay in Denmark that
would be a legal purpose entering
Denmark but while the Danish police have
loosened the restrictions on people
coming across the border into Denmark on
the other side their German colleagues
have abandoned them which is exactly
what many people in that part of Germany
have been hoping for for months people
like bound Christensen who manages a
number of shops just down the road from
the border before Corona came almost all
of the customers here was Scandinavian
then suddenly almost all could no longer
come here it was a huge issue because
the shutdown happened on March 13th when
Denmark announced no entry or exit and
shortly afterwards Germany followed suit
we've had three months of total loss and
that's three months of total loss where
you can't reduce your ongoing costs
that's extreme sentiments like that are
shared across Europe where many
countries hope reopening borders will
help restart their stalled economies as
here between France and Italy and in the
French capital the authorities are now
allowing bars and restaurants to reopen
fully including eating inside from
Monday at the EU level officials are
coordinating programs to provide
citizens with up-to-date information
about border reopening and other travel
issues during the pandemic reopen EU
offers practical information provided by
each member state to the Commission on
travel restrictions oblique health and
safety measures such as physical
distancing wearing of masks as well as
other useful information on EU and
national tourism activities during the
course of the coronavirus closures
Germany turned back almost 200
thousand people who tried to cross its
frontiers with other European countries
now it believes the time is right to
reopen those borders
Dominic Kane al Jazeera on the German
Danish border